mais cette semaine j'ai été critiqué par
ardisson
dieu sait si j'en met plein la tête mais
quelque part ça m'a plutôt flatté parce
qu'il est brillant
oui mais aujourd'hui j'ai été critiqué
par celui qui est j'espère qu'il nous
regarde pas ce qu'il a jamais rien à
[ __ ] voilà la définition du raté dans
thierry moreau vous êtes dur non non non
non c'est pas dur thierry moreau qui
s'est pris pour un grand animateur radio
etc a planté europe 1 en été qui s'est
pris pour un grand auteur et qui a écrit
que dans télé 7 jours qui s'est pris
pour un grand chroniqueur et qui a
quitté tpm paix dans l'anonymat le plus
total et qui se prend aujourd'hui pour
un grand journaliste alors que personne
ne parle de lui nous franchement je te
le dis j'espère que tu ne regardes
thierry moreau plutôt que de me cacher
je te le dis très franchement ta vie
ressemble à ta carrière ratée
alors moi je ne réagirai pas là dessus
mais qu'est ce qu'il a dit sur vous
parce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui lui a
demandé qui vraiment vous zappez à
l'antenne comme animateur et il a dit
matthieu delormeau c'est la bêtise et la
vacuité et encore je me reprends en fait
non il n'est pas animateur voilà voilà
et je précise en plus voulu préciser
vous être leader tnt tous les vendredis
absolument et je précise en plus quand
même je rajoute a raté lâche je sais que
le sait déjà
puisque côté à côté de moi analyse et
gentillesse et un jour une chroniqueuse
très gentiment agathe pour la nommer m'a
montré les textos alors qu'il était
assis à côté de moi où il envoyait des
horreurs sur moi c'est à dire qu'à côté
de moi il est gentil et dans mon dos
évidemment c'est un petit lâche quand il
aurait suscité joey starr qui vous
montre les textos jure voie là
lâche et raté ça fait beaucoup pour un
seul il a réussi cet exploit il est
énervé il énervé quand mathieu de long
et colère ouais parce que j'aime bien
taclé par des gens que j'admire malgré
tout quelque peu quelques parqués dans
des cages mais quand c'est pas des ratés
comme ça et gris ça me fait chier et
coûté en tout cas il a il à son droit de
réponse
voilà merde là que vous n'avez pas été
trop dur j'étais sincère je vous dire ne
croise pas dire i owe calme toi quand
même